Clap bonjour ! C'est Fabixem.
Alors aujourd'hui on va se faire un nouveau casse tête, c'est pas réellement un casse tête même si c'en est un, c'est une des boîtes secrète...
japonaise, faite de manière artisanale, qui est juste superbement magnifique. Juste l'histoire de la boîte elle est ouf...
l'histoire de l'histoire de faire ce genre de boîte c'est ouf, et je sais pas trop ce que ça va donner.
La seule chose que je sais, moi, et donc que je peux vous dire, c'est qu'elle se résout en 12 mouvements. Quand on achète ce genre de boîte
on sait le nombre de mouvements à faire
pour pouvoir l'ouvrir. Donc 12 mouvements, c'est pas si mal, je pense qu'il y a matière à faire une vidéo.
Et peut-être même 2, on verra bien.
Je pense quand même que si on trouve les, genre, 4-5 premiers, après en tâtonnements, on peut aller jusqu'au bout.
Juste avant de commencer la vidéo, je vous rappelle que je fais aussi des petites vidéos de gros plans et de ralentis de casse tête...
sur mon Instagram avec IGTV, vous êtes de plus en plus nombreux et nombreuses à le suivre et ça fait plaisir !
N'hésitez pas à les voir et puis à me dire là bas que vous venez d'ici.
*Accordéon*
Comme ça on retrouve. Et tant que j'y suis, je vous rappelle également que la date de l'Olympia, elle approche, c'est juste après les vacances
que je dévoile l'intégralité du nouveau spectacle à l'Olympia, et on est à 80% de remplissage, donc si vous voulez venir
il est temps de prendre votre place. C'est parti !
Alors, ce coffret Yosegi il se fait en 12 étapes. Il y en a qui se font 4 étapes, en 8 étapes... Ca c'est un 12 étapes.
Donc c'est relativement dur. D'autant que je connais un petit peu ces coffrets, il est produit réellement
artisanalement sur le lac Ashi au Japon, c'est fait dans un village d'artisans qui font des travaux de marqueterie depuis plus de 300 ans,
300 ans qu'ils font ça, aussi, des boites. Et ces travaux de marqueterie qui datent de 1600, 1700...
voire début 1800, ont la particularité de suivre toujours
la forme naturelle du bois, la couleur naturelle du bois, les les nervures naturelles du bois, et avec...
un procédé de rabotage très spécial, ils fabriquent ce genre de boîte...
qui sont à la fois une vraie boîte dont on peut se servir, mais aussi une boîte secrète à ouverture secrète. Et là, le seul...
indice qu'on ait, c'est qu'il y a 12 mouvements à trouver afin d'ouvrir la boîte.
Donc, dans un premier temps pour moi, ce que je veux comprendre...Bon déjà j'appuie là, ok là il y a un mouvement.
Dans un premier temps, ce que je veux comprendre, c'est "qu'est-ce qui doit s'ouvrir". Alors c'est en général
la grande partie supérieure
qui s'ouvre et qui coulisse, je pense que ce sera le cas, mais pour l'instant j'ai pas trop d' indices.
Là quand j'ai appuyé ici, en fait, assez naturellement c'est venu ici.
Donc je vais essayer de voir déjà, qu'est-ce qui bouge un peu partout.
Après ça peut bouger aussi en diagonale.
12 mouvements, c'est à la fois chaud et à la fois assez simple.
Parce ce que en général il y a un ordre séquencé aussi.
C'est la 3 ou 4ème vidéo là,
de casse-tête sur la chaîne. Si vous avez des idées de casse tête que vous voulez que
je résolve, vous avez été nombreux par exemple à me parler d'Excalibur...
Chris Ramsay l'a fait sur sa chaîne, je regardais, ça a l'air bien badass, c'est bien bien ouf.
Je vais voir comment me le procurer, comment le commander,
où le commander... Je pense que j'essaierai de le faire sur la chaîne, mais pas en une seule vidéo ça c'est sûr.
Bon, j'avais vraiment que ici que ça bouge.
OK, là ça a bougé aussi. Donc, en fait, ça nous fait un mouvement ici et un mouvement là.
Je trouve ça ouf, tout le système, en fait, mécanique qui permet la résolution
alors que tout est fait à la main, en bois, ça je trouve ça vraiment génial.
Et puis là nous, on a on un vrai indice. C'est-à-dire que quand tu te procures la boite, tu sais le nombre de mouvements.
Il y en a 2.
2 c'est pas mal.
Ou alors si ça se trouve, c'est ça qui s'enlève et j'ai pas compris.
Je sais pas si...
vous avez bien vu, mais en fait je viens de pouvoir le pousser plus loin. Alors attend, c'était comme ça, donc ça ferait 1
peut-être 4... 4... 5...
OK, donc j'ai 4 mouvements pour l'instant.
Premier mouvement je descends... Non, premier mouvement je pousse, ensuite je descends, ensuite je peux pousser plus loin...
et ensuite je descends. C'est tellement malin !
C'est un peu... Des fois c'est un peu un hasard, tu as un truc qui bouge...
Alors là je cherche s'il n'y a pas un retour ou quoi. 1... 2... 3... 4...
A priori, pour l'instant, je ne peux plus rien toucher de cette face, donc je peux aller chercher sur une autre face,
parce qu'il est possible...
OK, on a un cinquième mouvement ici. Alors après ça bute, pourquoi ça bute ?
Donc ça bute parce que là, il y a un tasseau de bois qui cherche à taper.
Donc l'idée c'est d'essayer de le visualiser en 3D.
Donc si ça tape là, ça veut dire qu'il faut que je le descende plus à un moment donné en fait.
En fait je me méfie, parce que dès que tu fais un autre mouvement ailleurs, tu te dis "OK, ça peut libérer quelque chose
sur quelque chose que moi j'ai déjà touché".
Là le truc c'est que... il n' y a plus rien qui bouge en fait, c'est très gênant [rires].
Depuis que j'ai fait ce cinquième mouvement, là, j'en trouve pas un sixième, nulle part.
Est-ce que c'est une diagonale... Ah, il y en a un là.
Je viens d'appuyer. En fait c'est ça, le secret, je crois, c'est vraiment d'appuyer un peu sur les bords...
plutôt que de faire ce que je faisais là, d'essayer de...
d'agripper avec mon pouce. C'est tellement fin que j'ai même pas vu que le ...
Eh oui, c'est ça ! Comme ils travaillent la nervure du bois, on voit même pas qu'il y a une séparation qui est faite ici. C'est complètement invisible !
C'est hallucinant !
En fait, si je le pousse pas, j'arrive pas à voir où est ce que ça va être.
Donc là, ça nous fait un sixième mouvement. 6 !
Bon, je vais reprendre la même mécanique que tout à l'heure du coup... 7
Peut-être 8...
Peut-être 9...
Peut-être 10...
Ca aurait été trop beau... Donc là, je suis à 10 mouvements.
C'est là que je suis à un mouvement d'ouvrir la boîte. On voit bien dans la boîte...
le tasseau, en fait, qui m'empêche de l'autre côté que ça marche. Même si je repousse d'ailleurs, ça donne... Et voilà !
Et là il y a une grande épaisseur.
Ce qui fait que le tasseau il tape dessus, en fait, qui sécurise le truc.
Donc ça fait 10 mouvements. Attends, je vais essayer de tous les refaire d'un coup.
Pour voir si ça me paraît assez logique. Donc ça ferait 1...
2...
3... 4... 5...
6... 7... 8...
9... Mais non ça fait 9 ça ! Ah non ça, ça fait que 9, il me manque 3 mouvements !
Donc là, ça change rien...
Ca, mécaniquement ça peut pas être connecté à ce côté là. Mon dernier truc, ça a été de baisser celui ci.
Si je le remonte, ça fait quoi ?
Non ça referme. [rires]
En fait si je le remonte, ça referme, c'était assez logique.
Est-ce qu'il est plus sorti que lui ?
Ou moins sorti ?
Ouais, il est clairement plus sorti ici...
que ici.
Et il rerentre. Voilà, c'est un vrai mouvement ça, ouais.
Donc ça, ça ferait un dixième mouvement... Je pense que je peux le rebaisser... 11 !
Et là j'ai clairement libéré le tasseau.
Donc en fait, c'était pas dans ce sens là, c'est dans ce sens là qu'il s'ouvre, voilà.
Et 12 !
Ouverture de la boîte 12 steps de Yosegi !
Je suis trop content !
C'est tellement joli ! C'est fait juste avec du bois noble, c'est très très joli. Et alors comment ça fonctionne à l'intérieur ?
Je vais essayer de voir.
Ah, c'est drôle ! Le mouvement, il reste secret, parce qu'il y a juste une toute petite rainure. On voit un petit tasseau à l'intérieur, qui bouge,
il doit descendre... Ah ouais d'accord !
En fait ça fait un chemin... C'est comme un petit labyrinthe à l'intérieur du truc.
Ah c'est ça !
Ce bois, là,
il est creusé à l'intérieur...
avec comme un petit système de labyrinthe pour un petit bout de bois qui doit faire le trajet en fait. Et c'est comme ça
qu'ils arrivent à faire ça. Bon, du coup, je la remonte.
Bon, je me le refais un coup en accéléré, pour voir si j'ai rien oublié. Donc 1... 2... 3... 4...
5...
6... 7... 8...
9... 10... 11... et 12... Et ça passe !
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo ! Vous avez vu, c'est flippant quand je suis très près !  Tu peux reculer un petit peu Loïc s'il te plait, merci ! [Rires]
Je suis persuadé qu'il y en a qui ont eu
peur sur leur téléphone ! Le lien, dans la description, comme d'habitude.
Le lien mon Insta aussi dans la description.
Je vous le rappelle, n'hésitez pas à venir dessus, je fais des vidéos que vous ne voyez que sur Insta, donc c'est assez cool.
Sur les casse-têtes, entre autres.
Likez la vidéo, si ça vous a plu, mettez moi dans les commentaires les noms de casse tête que vous aimeriez que je résolve sur la chaîne.
C'est pas facile à conjuguer, "résolve", "résoudre", tout ça... Et puis abonnez-vous si ce n'est pas déjà fait ! A très bientôt !
Ciao !